you know I've been thinking a lot lately
about how lucky we are to live in the
land of the free as opposed to an
autocratic country like Russia or China
you see in Putin's Russia the Press
isn't free instead it serves the
interests of the regime on whose behalf
it spreads lies and propaganda can you
imagine
even worse is communist China
in communist China citizens are under
constant surveillance the government
knows pretty much every single move they
make regardless of any nominal rights to
privacy in Russia and China citizens
don't have a practical right to free
speech even if they have such a right in
theory if they ever contradict the
prevailing Orthodoxy of the regime they
can be censored and kicked out of the
Public Square
in those kinds of countries agents of
the state even deny parents right to
raise their own children law enforcement
persecutes people for their traditional
religious beliefs and most brazenly of
all evil autocrats like Xi Jinping and
Vladimir Putin jail their political
opponents
thank goodness we don't live in a
country
like that thank goodness we don't live
in a country like oh look what does this
card say right here it says president
Trump might be arrested on Tuesday huh
that's weird uh this according to
president Trump though it comes after an
NBC report that prosecutors in New York
are preparing to indict
Trump what are they going to indict him
over
is it Russia collusion is it Ukraine
collusion is it is classified documents
that Biden apparently had multiples of
at his home that didn't really matter it
was only when Trump had it that was a
bad thing no no it's none of that
the libs in New York are looking to
indict Trump
over his hush money payment to Stormy
Daniels
back in 2016.
they've gone through so many attempts to
try to get Trump they're now onto reruns
they're now going back to the originals
and so what's the what's the issue here
why is it a crime for Trump to pay
Stormy Daniels
well
he paid it through Michael Cohen who is
his former attorney who sang like a
songbird and now and completely turned
on Trump broke under pressure and uh got
a slightly more lenient treatment
apparently by the Liberals than he
otherwise would have would have gotten
he says that he made the payment on
Trump's behalf two Stormy Daniels to
keep her quiet about an alleged 2006
Affair that they had
then Cohen pleaded guilty to related
charges and served time in prison
why is it a crime because the payment
was listed as a legal expense
and the company cited a retainer
agreement with Cohen
but the this particular retainer
apparently did not exist even though
Cohen was Trump's lawyer for a long time
there was no legal retainer in this
particular incident and so
Trump may have committed a misdemeanor
of falsifying business records
the report said that Trump personally
signed several checks to Cohen while he
was serving as president
now a misdemeanor why are you going to
arrest the former president and the
current chief rival to the sitting
president over a misdemeanor well they
can elevate it to a felony if they can
prove that Trump's quote intent to
defraud included an intent to commit or
conceal a second crime and the libs are
arguing that the second crime is that
the hundred thirty thousand dollars
hush money payment to Stormy Daniels was
actually an improper political
contribution because he was making the
payment to keep her quiet during the
campaign so it's as though it were an
improper donation to The Campaign which
again is bogus pretty much every
campaign Finance matter is bogus because
money is fungible so if you if you give
x amount of money to a candidate's
Campaign Committee that can land you in
prison but if you give 10 times that
amount of money to a Super PAC that's
totally fine if one group gives money
it's okay if an individual or a
different group gives money that can
that can be a big problem so it's all
basically bogus but the reason this is
especially bogus is that Trump is the
candidate and candidates can give as
much money to their campaigns as they
want so even if the prosecutors in New
York argue that this was an improper
donation to The Campaign maybe it was
done through a kind of improper Channel
maybe the paperwork was a little bit off
but it's still Donald Trump donating to
his own campaign it's so patently absurd
it's so obvious that the Democrats here
just want to stop the people from having
a chance to re-elect Donald Trump
because they're afraid that if Trump can
appear on a ballot they're afraid that
if Trump can mount a real presidential
campaign that the people will vote for
him and so they're doing everything they
can they tried to disqualify him using
the 14th Amendment they tried to uh they
had multiple suits to try to keep him
off the ballots in different states
around the country they have tried to
impeach him multiple times they Trot now
they're trying to lock him into prison
from from which place he could still run
for president but who obviously would
hurt his campaign if he were stuck in a
jail cell instead of holding rallies
it's so obvious
that these guys fear Trump and want to
do everything they can to prevent the
people from having a choice that this is
the silver lining of this whole storm
cloud
the Silver Lining is
that I think we can finally dismiss once
and for all all the ridiculous piffle
that the Democrats tell us about
our sacred democracy
our Donald Trump and the Republicans are
a threat to our
sacred temples of democracy are
cherished norms we don't act like this
in America we're better than this no
you're not better than this you're
breaking all the Norms you are
undermining our allegedly sacred
democracy you're jailing your political
opponents like a two-bit dictator in a
Banana Republic which
some of us conservatives have observed
for a long time
so okay that's how they want to play
fine I do not want to hear it anymore
about our sacred democracy or any of
that other stuff
don't want to hear it one little bit
what should the Republicans do in
response I think
that a republican governor
or more precisely I guess a republican
Attorney General
should arrest a prominent criminal lib
there is no shortage of candidates of
prominent liberal politicos who have
committed crimes
look around the Clinton circles look
around the Biden circles look at Clinton
and Biden themselves
plenty of big criminal Libs out there
who have completely gotten off the hook
and there are plenty of Republican
Governors and Attorneys General out
there
I think you would need a republican
Governor as well as an attorney general
because if the Attorney General
indicts a big prominent
criminal lib
and and there's a Democrat Governor the
Democrat Governor will apply political
pressure or eventually probably just
pardon the criminal lib so I think you
need to have a republican Governor there
as well but let's do it let's let's
indict a big criminal lib let's let's
indict two of them
that they are going after our guy let's
go after five of their guys
there's no risk here some people push
back against this suggestion they say
well we're better than them Michael
we're yeah sure I think we are better
than them I'm not suggesting we do
anything illegal or unjust
I'm not saying we go after an innocent
live I'm saying we should go after a
criminal live against him the law has
not been applied the argument against
doing that is that we want to preserve
our norms and we don't want to live in a
country where we throw the the
vanquished political opposition into
orange jumpsuits I agree I don't want to
live in that country but
the only reason for which we should be
concerned about that Norm is if the norm
continues to exist the libs are breaking
that Norm that's not our fault we have
nothing to say we're saying don't
violate the norm don't don't start
arresting the opposition leaders in our
country but if they're if they're going
to do that then we've got to play the
game otherwise we're just surrendering
to the people who are abusing our
political system the most so okay they
want to indict Trump fine I I want to
see every Republican governor and
attorney general with the political
Capital with the power to do so to
indict prominent criminal Libs and I
think you should indict multiple and you
should throw the book at them and you
should find every stupid little fake
misdemeanor charge and you should trump
it up as high as you possibly can okay
you the the the reason that you have to
do this the reason this would be good
for our political order is because it
would show
the libs that there are consequences to
their actions it would discourage
further predations on our political
order I remember the great the late
great historian Donald Kagan
professor of Mining College historian of
war and specifically of ancient Greece
in the Peloponnesian War
and when he would get down to these
margin calls why did Pericles do this
why did this Statesman do that he would
say
my inclination is to what motivated this
Statesman in this action
or in this in this strategy
comes from one place and it's the
Brooklyn school yard and because Donald
Kagan grew up in Brooklyn is kind of a
tough New York kid became a very
distinguished Professor he said the
Brooklyn schoolyard the rules hold the
same the rules of war the rules of
politics they're the exact same as when
you walk up to a bully in the playground
okay and so if we do not push back if we
just roll over and allow the libs to
start resting the leader of the
opposition in the United States
we say well we're preserving the Norms
you're not preserving any Norm you're
you are helping the Liberals to
establish a new Norm which is that the
conservatives never have a shot to win
and if conservatives ever stand up
against the regime in any significant
way they will be wearing an orange
jumpsuit now the silver lining for Trump
here
is
they restored his YouTube account
that's I just imagine Trump having a
meeting with the regime Trump having a
meeting with the ruling class and they
say hey Donald
hey opposition party we've got good news
and bad news
and what's the good news well the good
news is
we're going to let you broadcast on
YouTube again so we're going to let you
back into the Public Square
you can post videos to YouTube oh great
what's the bad news you can do it from
prison there's trade-offs in life and
and the timing is so weird they announce
this just as the rumors start flying
that that they're going to arrest Trump
it seems coordinated
it seems and so much of our ruling class
seems coordinated the media coordinates
with the government big Tech coordinates
with the Deep State we know that they
have regular meetings with the FBI and
the FBI says don't post this story it's
going to be damaging to Joe Biden don't
allow people even to privately message
the story about Hunter Biden's laptop
okay sounds good and there's all this
coordination that goes on
and now the very same day hey we're
gonna let Trump back on YouTube isn't
that fair by the way we're going to
arrest him okay the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code Knowles kwles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans we will see you over at the
member room segment room
[Music]
thank you
foreign